Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ahmet Tutordo. Ich bin hier als Erstennarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen in diese Aufnahme gespürt.
Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstanden. Wie heißen Sie?
Ja, ich heiße Marion Engel und ich komme hier wegen meines Sohnes Marwin.
Marwin.
Marwin mit V in der Mitte.
Ah, okay.
M-A-R-D-I-N.
M-A-R-V-I-N. Marwin.
Marwin.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Nachname?
Engel.
Marwin Engel ist das Kind.
Okay. Wie alt ist Ihre Sonne?
Ja, Marwin ist jetzt ziemlich genau neun Jahre. Der hat ihn ein paar Tage Geburtstag.
Neun Jahre?
Mhm.
Okay. Wann hat er jenoy geboren?
Er ist am 15.02.2013 geboren.
Am 15.02.2013.
Ah, 2000.
2013.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Wie lange ist Ihre Sonne?
Sie meinen wie groß?
Ja, wie groß?
Ja, ich meine, letzte Mal war so 1,31.
Okay.
Wie schwer ist der?
Ja, ich meine, 28 kg wiegt er.
Der steht da nicht still auf der Wage. Aber ich meine, so 28 kg hatte er.
28 kg. Okay.
Was fand ich für ein Zitron?
Ja, also, der Marwin ist echt mein Sorgenkind.
Der, ja, ich dachte erst, das hängt vielleicht in unserer familiären Situation zusammen,
aber jetzt scheint es doch irgendwie realer zu sein.
Ich dachte immer, er hat vielleicht keine Lust, in die Schule zu gehen
oder hat immer über Bauchschmerzen geklagt.
Und jetzt fällt mir eben auf, dass er doch sehr oft Durchfall hat
und dass er auch nicht gut ist.
Und ja, manchmal sagt das dann auch nicht.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, ja, ist vielleicht doch nicht so schlimm.
Ich dachte so ein bisschen, er will sich vielleicht vor der Schule drücken.
Aber nein, das scheint doch irgendwie ernsthaft zu sein.
Seit wann haben Sie, hat er diese Fischwerden?
Das ist jetzt schon ziemlich lange.
Das ist bestimmt schon, ja, fast ein halbes Jahr.
Und ja, wissen Sie, ich habe mich jetzt gerade vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
von meinem Mann getrennt und die Kinder sind halt bei mir.
Dann habe ich gedacht, das hängt vielleicht damit zusammen,
dass er irgendwie so unter Druck ist.
Aber, na ja, und jetzt hat er dann auch tatsächlich ein bisschen
am Gewicht verloren.
Ich meine, er hat schon mehr gewogen.
Und ja, er ist einfach schlecht dran.
Muss man dazusagen, dass Marvin schon als kleines Kind,
haben wir das festgestellt, dass er Diabetiker ist.
Ja, und ja.
Aber er ist eigentlich, weil er immer gut eingestellt mit Insulin.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Er ist auch Insulin eingestellt.
Das hat der Arzt alles gemacht.
Und das machen wir halt nach Schema.
Aber ja, er ist halt auch ein merkeliger Esser.
Er mag überhaupt nicht die Sachen, die eigentlich gut wären für ihn.
Er ist ganz wenig Obst und Gemüse,
was natürlich für ihn als Diabetiker gut wäre.
Und ja, und jetzt geht es ihm also wirklich ganz schlecht.
Und jetzt bin ich wirklich in großer Sorge.
Sie haben gesagt, er hat manchmal durchgefahren.
Ja, also inzwischen ist es wirklich 2-3 Mal in der Woche.
Und das sind richtig heftige Durchfälle.
Richtig, mit Bauchschmerzen, oder?
Und Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Bauchschmerzen.
Okay, aber dieser Bauchschmerzen ist kollekartig, oder?
Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, da.
Ich kann das gar nicht.
Wie beschreiben Kinder Bauchschmerzen, ja?
Er sagt halt, man baucht so weh.
Und also aufgefallen sich mir das neulich mal,
da hatten wir Nudeln gegessen.
Und danach war es dann ganz schlecht.
Ah, nach dem Nudeln, ja?
Okay.
Wie ist es mit Brot?
Ja, da ist es eigentlich,
ja sonst, wir essen natürlich ja nicht immer warm,
sondern abends und morgens ist der Brot.
Und da ist es auch manchmal so, ja.
Okay.
Okay, dann.
Sie haben das, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, seit halb Jahren diese,
bemerkt, waren Sie früher für diese Bauchschmerzen
einem anderen Arzt, oder?
Nein, ich habe das ja, wie gesagt,
auf die spezielle Situation geschoben
und habe eben auch gedacht,
dass er in der Schule irgendwie Probleme hat.
Die Lehrerin hat mir jetzt auch gesagt,
dass er eigentlich ein bisschen,
ja unkonzentriert ist im Unterricht.
Und ich habe das eben auch,
so ob unsere familiäre Situation geschoben.
Und habe halt gedacht, ja, gib ihm ein bisschen Zeit,
sich wieder zu fangen und sich an die Situation zu gewöhnen.
Aber das jetzt irgendwie macht mir das jetzt doch große Sorgen.
Okay.
Hat er erst erbrochen in dieser Station?
Nein, das ist mir nie aufgefallen.
Nein, hat er auch nichts von gesagt.
Oder hat er gesagt, Überkeit?
Nein, eigentlich nur Bauchschmerzen.
Okay.
Ja, ich möchte einige Fragen mit
Ihren Station,
mit Ihrem Seinen-Sonststation.
Ja, ein bisschen Übergreifen.
Gib das Fieber?
Fieber ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nee, der war nie warm oder fieberig
oder hat sich schlecht gefühlt in der Hinsicht.
Nee.
Oder ich weiss Ausbrüche zum Beispiel in der Nacht.
Ist das ist mir überhaupt nicht aufgefallen?
Nein.
Okay.
Was mir aufgefallen ist tatsächlich,
dass er ziemlich häufig
Wasser lassen muss.
Er geht also häufig auf die Toilette.
Häufig.
Wie oft zum Beispiel in der
Zeit?
Ja, vielleicht schon so am
Nachmittag so viermal oder so.
Und ich glaube, in der Schule geht er zwischendurch
auch immer noch mal raus.
Ja, in der Nacht.
Nein, in der Nacht glaube ich nicht.
Er schläft da eigentlich durch.
Okay, in der Nacht mit der Zeit,
viermal.
Stimmt ja.
Okay.
Gibt es Schütterfrost
oder haben Sie das bemerkt?
Nee, nee, nee.
Also so Fieberanzeichen und so was hat er nicht.
Okay.
Genug Wasser.
Ja, doch.
Also Trinkentute eigentlich schon ganz gut.
Ja, also ich mach dann Tee oder mal Trinktasaft.
Cola und so was darf er ja natürlich nicht wegen des Diabetes.
Aber mal, mal so ein Orangensaft
oder so was, das Trinktaschon.
Aber nicht so wenig, oder?
Bitte?
Nicht extrem wenig.
Nicht so wenig, oder?
Nee.
Ja, vielleicht sogar ein bisschen viel.
Okay, dann.
Hat er Husten?
Husten?
Nee, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, er hat Diabetika.
Hat er andere Foreachrankungen?
Ja, vor zwei Jahren musste er mal operiert werden
im kleinen Eingriff wegen eines Leistenbruchs.
Leistenbruch?
Welche Seite?
Link oder rechte?
Rechte.
Okay.
Gibt es andere Operationen?
Nein, sonst nichts.
Okay.
Hat er ein Unfall gemacht, oder haben Sie das?
Unfall hatte ich nie erlebt.
Nein, nein, nein. Gott sei Dank, bisher nicht.
Nein, ich hoffe, das bleibt so.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, er nutzt Insulin.
Ja.
Wie oft und dosierer kennen Sie das?
Ich habe ein Schema hier, das kann ich Ihnen zeigen.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie andere mit dem weiteren Medikament?
Nein, sonst nicht.
Nein, er hat sonst weitergekriegt.
Nein.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Engel, kommen Sie jetzt?
Nein.
Nein, nein.
Ja, tatsächlich ist mir jetzt in letzter Zeit mal aufgefallen.
Das ist aber wirklich ganz neu,
dass er oben an den Armen so einen Ausschlag hat.
Das hat er an beiden Armen.
Ausschlag.
Aber woher das kommt, das habe ich noch nicht rausgefunden.
Haben Sie eine auslösende Faktor per Meck oder für das?
Nein, ich habe keine Ahnung, woher das kommt.
Das ist jetzt auch ja ganz neu.
Neu und Sie haben das nur einmal gesehen, oder?
Seitdem, also seit kurzer Zeit, hat er das, seit zwei Wochen?
Seit zwei Wochen.
Okay.
Kennen Sie eine Unverträglichkeit zum Beispiel?
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, mehr nach dem Nudeln Druckfall.
Ja, da hat er halt Bauchschmerzen bekommen, genau.
Oder Fructose oder Laktose, Unverträglichkeit.
Bisher war da nichts bekannt, ne?
Okay.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ich frage Ihnen.
Ja, fast.
Ich habe das einzige Problem, was ich habe.
Ich habe tatsächlich Geilensteine,
aber die sind bisher noch nicht operiert worden.
Zwischendurch habe ich da mal kurz beschwerden
und dann legt sich das aber wieder
und da habe ich Gott sei Dank keine Probleme.
Okay.
Wie ist der Vater?
Der ist grundsätzlich auch gesund, der hat ein bisschen erhöht
den Blutdruck.
Okay.
Ja, hat Marvin Geschwister?
Er hat ein Bruder.
Ah, Bruder.
Ist seine Bruder gesund oder sein Bruder?
Der Bruder ist gesund, ja, zum Glück, ja.
Okay.
Ja, der Marvin ist unser Sorgenkind, ne?
Okay, okay, aber keine Sorgen.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Und Vater?
Der Vater hat gelegentlich mal geraucht, aber nie in der Wohnung.
Gelegentlich geraucht.
Okay.
Okay, dann.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Ah, geschieden.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ja.
Okay.
Und Sie leben mit?
Ich lebe mit den Kindern zusammen, ne?
Kinder.
Diese Kinder sind bei mir.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, diese Situation war problematisch.
Ja, natürlich.
Deswegen habe ich auch alles da drauf geschoben.
Weil ich gedacht habe, dass die Kinder irgendwie vielleicht auch,
gerade jetzt Marvin, als sensibles Kind,
vielleicht darauf reagiert.
Deswegen habe ich das alles da drauf geschoben.
Deswegen komme ich auch jetzt erst damit.
Aber es wird hier irgendwie gar nicht besser.
Und jetzt habe ich gedacht, müssen wir doch mal danach gucken.
Okay.
Ja, diese Situation ist problematisch für Kinder.
Ich denke, das ist ja auch.
Und okay, dann haben Sie finanzielle Probleme, oder?
Bitte was?
Finanzielle Probleme.
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Finanzielle.
Was ist Ihr vom Beruf?
Ich bin Sekretärin.
Sekretärin.
Okay, dann.
Ich arbeite halt Teilzeit, damit ich dann,
wenn die Schule vorbei ist, nach den Kindern gucken kann.
Sie arbeiten Teilzeit.
Okay.
Ja, das ist für Kinder gut, wie ich denke.
Okay, dann Frau Engel.
Ja, ich habe meine wichtige Fragen gefragt.
Ich möchte jetzt nur natürlich wissen, was mit dem Marvin ist
und was man dagegen tun kann.
Und ja, ob das mit dem Diabetes zusammenhängt
und ja, was wir tun können, damit es ihm wieder besser geht.
Okay, also ist es möglich,
körperlich und persönlich machen.
Wir können über das sprechen und dann über die Situation.
Ich bin auch noch nicht mehr sicher,
dass ich das nicht mehr so gut finde.
Wir können über das sprechen und ja,
diese Situation habe ich denke, nicht schlechte Situation,
sondern denke ich, das ist ein Verträglichenproblem.
Okay.
Aber wir können das jetzt nach dem Untersuchen
und Blutatnahme und ja,
das ist gut.
Ja, das tut ihm aber nicht weh, ne?
Ultraschalluntersuchen tut ihm nicht weh, ne?
Ja, nicht weh.
Es ist Schemaßdose.
Das ist gut, ja.
Ja, und deswegen ist es kein Problem.
Und ja, nachdem diese Kruste ausröckeln,
wir sprechen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay.
Ja, klar bin ich gespannt, was die raushinken.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Besorgter Mutter.
Ja, aber ich denke, schon leer, aber.
Ja, klar.
Bingo sozusagen.
Ja, gut.
Die Kollegen, die Kollegen, alle sind erschlagen.
Okay.
Gut.
Ja, wollen wir gleich weiter machen mit dem Arztgespräch?
Oder wollen Sie ein bisschen noch sacken und aufschreiben?
Ja, ein oder zwei Minuten ja.
Ja, gut, okay.
Ich trinke so lange Tee.
Ja, ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Wie viele Kilogramm hat er abgenommen?
Und gibt es nur im Stuhl?
Ah, zwei gute Fragen, ja.
Ja, das war wichtig.
Gut, also Blut hat er nicht im Stuhl.
Und, ähm, oder ist der Mutter zumindest nicht aufgefallen?
Okay.
Und er hat in letzter Zeit 3 Kilo abgenommen.
Ja, in 4 Monaten.
Okay.
Welche Probleme, nochmal die ganze Latte von Problemen.
Da kam gerade eine Wortmeldung.
Eine schriftliche Meldung.
Soll ich nochmal alle Symptome sagen?
Alle Symptome.
Nee, es kam gerade eine schriftliche,
eine schriftliche Anfrage.
Soll nochmal.
Probleme wiederholen.
Aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, das waren ja 1000 Probleme.
Ein Patienteporstellung vielleicht.
Noch mal von vorne.
Also.
Das Kind hat Verdauungsprobleme,
Bauchschmerzen nach dem Essen.
Ist von Natur aus Diabetik, also von,
von Staat an Diabetiker.
Und, ähm,
fällt jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist eine Frage,
die ich mir auch schon mal,
ich finde,
das war es eigentlich schon.
Und, ähm,
fällt jetzt eben auf durch, durch,
äh, ja, Appetitlosigkeit, Gewichtsverlust,
äh, häufiges Wasserlassen.
Ja,
wässrige Durchfälle und Bauchschmerzen,
speziell nach dem Essen.
Und, ähm,
ja, das war es eigentlich auch schon.
Und wir,
wir waren eigentlich auf durch
Teilnahmslosigkeit, Unkonzentrierteheit.
Hat der Probleme,
wenn er mich trinkt?
Hat der Probleme, wenn er mich trinkt?
Das weiß ich tatsächlich nicht so ganz genau.
Ähm, ähm,
das, also sagen wir so,
das ist der Mutter nicht aufgefallen,
um das mal jetzt sehr diplomatisch
aus der Schlinge zu ziehen.
Keine Ahnung, ähm,
Also sie hat ja gesagt, er trinkt gut, er trinkt Milch und Tee und Saft und ja, die Bauchschmerzen
sind halt eigentlich nicht so zwingend nur durch die Milch verursacht auf alle Fälle.
Ah ja, okay, gut, gerne.
Vielleicht ist es so eine Frage, auch können wir stellen.
Also Schlafstörungen nach Schweiß oder Abtrauen in Silindosen, so können wir denken.
Ja, also ist jetzt nicht beschrieben, überhaupt nicht.
Und ich weiß halt zu wenig, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, jetzt von mir aus,
ich bin ja nicht die echte Mutter, ich weiß zu wenig über den kindlichen Diabetes 1.
Ich kann da jetzt also wirklich nicht aus dem Nähekästchen flauen und sagen, so und so ist das Kind.
Ja, weiß ich wirklich nicht, müsste ich jetzt irgendwie mir was zusammenreimen, kann ich aber nicht.
Aber eigentlich ist es nicht, im Fall jetzt hier ist es nicht beschrieben, überhaupt nicht.
Ja, können wir?
Ja, gut.
Okay, guten Abend.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patient vorstellen, habt ihr das seit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, mein Patient ist Martin Engel, neun Jahre alt und 28 Kilogramm.
131 cm.
Man kann zu uns mit seiner Mutter und habe Bauchschmerzen.
Ach gut.
Nein.
Hat er gut Bauchschmerzen gehabt?
Ja, er hat Bauchschmerzen gehabt, er hat uns vorhin geholfen,
er hat Bauchschmerzen seit halb Jahren aufgetreten.
Ach so lange schon?
Ja, und nachdem ich aufgetreten habe,
ja, und außerdem habe er die Jahre attaquen auch,
wie häufig?
Wie häufig, zwei oder dreimal pro Woche.
Ja, okay.
Und außerdem in diesem Zeitraum habe er fünf Kilogramm in diesem Vier-Morart.
Abgenomen.
Drei Kilo, das bleibt nichts über von dem Kind.
Ja, außerdem, vor der Vegetative Annemnaise ergab sich Poliuri,
und Poliuri, Nekturi, ja, und, nein, Nekturi, Poliuri.
Und voneinander, er gab sich, habe er Diabetes mellitus Tip 1,
und nehme er in die Zulin.
Und ist der eigentlich gut eingestellt, der Diabetes?
Ja.
Ob der Diabetes gut eingestellt ist?
Ja, ich denke, ja.
Ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Sostand nach Ingoliner Herrni.
Er nehme Medikamente nur ins Sulin, ich habe das gesagt.
Ja, der Genalemnese ergab sich,
und er hat die Exemme seit zwei Wochen aufgetreten im Oberan,
beide Oberalme, und die Familie, seine Mutter kennen keine Verträglichkeit.
Und nochmal bitte, seine Mutter?
Keine Unverträglichkeit.
Ach so, Sie kennen keine Unverträglichkeit, ja.
Ja, der Familie an dem Nese ergab sich,
Mutter hat Coletiasis, und Vater hat Arteriepertonie.
Ja, in der, ich habe das gefragt,
ob sie in der Haus brauchen oder nicht.
Und Vater manchmal.
Aber er ist nicht jetzt in der Haus, aber früher.
Ich denke, weil sie geschieben,
und diese Kinder lebt mit ihrer Mutter jetzt.
Also die Mutter war mit dem Kind da, und die Kinder leben auch weiter.
Ja, und, ja, und...
Hat er noch Geschwister?
Ja, er hat einen Bruder, auch, aber es ist gesund.
Gesund? Ja.
Und seine Frau ist, seine Mutter ist Sekretärin tätig,
und Teil sei bearbeitet.
Ja, aufgrund der erwandten Angaben gehe ich auf einer Verdachtdiatmose
auf Choliakar aus.
Choliakir?
Ja, Choliakir.
Alternativ kommt zum Beispiel infektiös ursachen,
was du entdeckst.
Ja, aber seit ein halben Jahr, was könnte es noch sein,
wenn es richtig blöd läuft auch?
Was kann sein?
Kohle und irritable ist hier angegeben,
dann ist Kron und Kohletis ulzerosa angegeben.
Kohletis ulzerosa.
Okay.
Ja, natürlich, im Kind vergleichsweise exotisch.
Ja, ja.
Was machen wir denn jetzt mit dem Marwen?
Was machen Sie denn jetzt mit dem Marwen bei der Untersuchung?
Okay.
Als erstes möchte ich körperlich untersuchen.
Warum achten Sie da besonders?
Okay.
Ich möchte als erstes diese Ausschlagen gesehen,
gesägen möchten.
Okay, ja.
Und dann möchte ich die Bauchmutz untersuchen.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Palpation des Bauchers?
Ja, mit der Palpation.
Ich denke, es kann normal sein.
Ich weiß nicht, was er gestern gegessen hat.
Ja, schlau, ja.
Deswegen, zum Beispiel, ich kann warten,
Methodismus, wenn er nullen ist oder brod ist.
Okay.
Und dann, ich kann das abhören auch.
Ja.
Und was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Labortechnisch für Choliaki.
Das war ein Test, ja.
Antikörper.
Passt schon gut, klingt schon gut an.
Ja, ich war das, aber ich hätte mir das jetzt nicht.
Also Antikörper gegen Gluten.
Ja.
Und dann wahrscheinlich erhöhte Entzündungsparameter.
Und was hier noch angegeben wurde,
erwartet ein Eisenmangel.
Und dass das Gesamteilweis er niedrig ist.
Ja, wegen Absorption.
Wegen der Absorption.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja, und Sie sagten, eine Sonografie wollen Sie machen?
Ja, ich möchte das machen, weil ich möchte andere Dinge auslösen.
Ja, andere.
Auslösen.
Ja, okay.
Das ist sicherlich sinnvoll.
Genau, okay.
Gut.
Wenn sich Ihr Verdacht bestätigt,
dann haben wir eine neue Anleitung.
Was wäre denn Ihre Empfehlung fürs weitere Vorgehen?
Okay.
Als erstes, Gluten kann es ist wichtig für mich.
Ja, was bedeutet das dann jetzt im Alltag tatsächlich?
Was bedeutet zum Beispiel,
ja, diese Kinder möchten viel nutzen.
Deswegen nur dann ohne Gluten,
zum Beispiel mit,
nicht mit Mehl von,
was?
Kein Weizen, ne?
Normalerweise nodeln bei uns mit Weizenmehl.
Ja.
Was soll das Kind denn,
statt Getreidesachen essen?
Was kann es essen?
Es ist natürlich so Gluten befreites Getreide.
Aber welche Stoffe sind denn von Natur aus Gluten frei?
Okay, ja, kann man zum Beispiel Reis essen.
Reis, genau.
Und ja, natürlich Obst, Gemüse
und vielleicht kein Problem.
Ja.
Es gibt viele Getreidearten, die ja vielleicht hier gar nicht so
vertraut sind in Deutschland, aber anderswo auf der Welt durchaus
und die gut gehen.
Also unsere klassischen 4 Getreidearten, die es hier gibt,
wäre Weizen, Roggen, Gerst, der Hafer sollen alle nicht.
Die Klassiker gehen alle nicht.
Aber Reis geht und Mais geht und Hirse geht.
Mais?
Ja, also Maismehl, das ist ja häufig in diesen
glutenfreien Broten, ist ja oft Maismehl drin.
Und Hirse geht und natürlich gehen auch Kartoffeln.
Das heißt, dieses Kind,
was also bisher wenig Obst und Gemüse gegessen hat,
muss seine Ernährung schon relativ radikal umstellen.
Ja, der Arme, kleine Kerl, ja.
Ja, Diabetiker auch, aber deswegen diese Reis, Mais
und ja, mit dieser Ernährung muss seine Frau,
seine Mutter aufmerksam sein.
Ja, sie muss sich richtig doll kümmern um die Ernährung
von diesem Kind, ganz genau, ja.
Und ich meine Erwachsene, die erleben ja selber
mit der Diät, was ihnen bekommt und was nicht.
Aber Kinder haben natürlich diese Einsicht nicht.
Und da ist das schon deutlich schwieriger.
Gut, wie ist das denn mit der Milch?
Milch, Milch, hier kommt so nichts, kein Problem.
Ich weiß nicht, wo das herkommt und was der Hintergrund ist.
Ich habe als Hinweis Laktose beschränken
und tatsächlich in den ersten Monaten bei Beginn der Diäten.
Ich habe Kontrolle.
Bitte?
Kontrolle oder diese Situation wegen Laktose?
Das habe ich überlegt, ob man das praktisch macht,
um eine parallele Laktose in Toleranz auszuschließen,
dass man die Milch weglässt.
Also hier steht in den ersten Monaten,
soll man ihnen keine Milch geben.
Ich habe keinen Hinweis dafür gefunden, warum.
Aber das scheint tatsächlich irgendwie so ein Ding zu sein.
Ich konnte mir vorstellen,
ich kann da auch irgendjemand von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
was zu sagen, dass man das macht,
um eine parallele Laktoseproblematik auszuschließen.
Und dann ist hier noch ein wichtiger Hinweis,
den ich eigentlich auch ganz klug finde,
praktisch Vitamin Substitution,
aufgrund der Resorptionsstörung.
Ja, richtig.
Und zwar die Fettmischlichen.
EDK und A, soll man substituieren,
natürlich ja immer mit Maß und Vorsicht.
Aber finde ich, also fand ich jetzt einen ganz interessanten Hinweis.
Gut, genau, B12, komm, ja.
Dann, wie lange muss denn diese Diät machen, der Junge?
Wie lange?
Wie lange muss diese Kind?
Die ED machen. Wird es irgendwann besser?
In seinem Leben?
Ja, in der Zeit.
Nein, diese Situation ist nachhaltig.
Ja, lang dauern, also lebenslang fragend ist, ne?
Ja, genau.
Genau, so.
Ja, da wird sich die Mutter aber nicht freuen.
Über die Information, ja.
Also, ich würde sagen, da ist ja alles gekommen.
Wieder, das ist irgendwie mir jetzt schon bei ganz vielen aufgefallen.
Die Anamnese ist immer super.
Die Präsentation ist ein bisschen stockend,
besprachlich nicht ganz so sicher.
Was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist,
wir haben ganz viel in ihren Computer geguckt
und mich nicht angeguckt, als Mutter oder als Patientin.
Ja, das ist vielleicht in der realen Situation dann anders.
Aber das muss man tatsächlich wirklich
ein bisschen auf den Schirm haben,
dass man Leute anguckt, mit denen man spricht.
Ich weiß, dass das sehr verlockend ist,
auf seine Dateien oder auf seine Notizen zu gucken.
Aber ich glaube, das nehmen auch die Prüferübel,
wenn sie die nicht angucken.
Also, ja, das nur als Hinweis.
Ja, sonst würde ich sagen,
ist da alles gekommen, was zum Thema kommen muss.
Und ich habe auch keine weiteren Fragen mehr.
Gut.
Okay.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, dann kann Marvin ja hoffentlich bald wieder fröhlich zur Schule gehen.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja, ich habe da ja auch in die Richtung ein bisschen hingearbeitet,
weil ich ja irgendwie eine Erklärung brauchte,
warum hat das Kind ein halbes Jahr lang Durchfall
und die Mutter kommt nicht zum Arzt, ja,
ist ja völlig bescheuert.
Und die Situation gab das natürlich ein bisschen her.
Scheidung der Eltern.
Und ja, ich glaube, jeder der Kinder,
hat kennt das, das Kind hat keine Lust zur Schule,
weil es geärgert wird von irgendjemandem.
Und ich herbauch, ich kann auch nicht in die Schule.
Und dann sage ich, ach, stelle dich nicht so an
und so schreibt ihr heute Deutsch test oder so.
Und insofern, warum hört man ein halbes Jahr lang nicht hin,
was mit dem Kind ist?
Spätestens nach zwei Monaten,
wenn man sich das nicht in die Schule hat,
dann ist es so,
spätestens nach zwei Monaten macht man doch eigentlich irgendwas.
Und die Mutter hat deswegen ja so ein bisschen gesagt,
hey, ich habe gedacht, na, wer vielleicht so?
Und ja, die wollte sich entschuldigen.
Kann ich meine Meinung sagen?
Gerne.
Immer.
Ja.
Bei diesem Patienten in diesem Alter,
19 Jahre, 9 Jahre und der Typ 1 Diabetes hat
und wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr heute kontrolliert werden müssen,
sollte auch eine Scholiakerkrankung,
meine Meinung nach,
differenziell diagnostisch in Betracht gesogen werden.
Von vornherein.
Ja.
Es ist sehr schwierig, diese Patienten zu diagnostizieren.
Bei diesem Bechwerten sollte unsere Patienten unbedingt
an eine Scholiakerkrankung dachten werden.
Aber erst mal,
verdacht Diagnose, meine Meinung,
und kontrolliert die Diabetes mellitus
und darmentripati.
Ja, praktisch wegen der schweren Grunderkrankung sozusagen.
Ja, weil diese Patienten
maximum 6 oder 7 Jahre diagnostiziert werden müssen,
diese sehr lange Jahre.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
3-Schioliac Diagnose, 3 Formen
und diese Jahre, 2. Form,
maximum 6 oder 7 Jahre diagnostiziert werden.
Es ist so spät.
Ja, so spät, ja.
Und diese Patienten,
die Diabetes mellitus,
und diese Symptome
für diese Patienten denken,
aber nicht andere.
Tip 1 Diabetes mellitus
und viele kontrollierten müssen.
Danach,
Also, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Genau genommen, hätte die Theliakie viel früher auffallen müssen,
weil der als Diabetes-Patient
eigentlich in der Dauerkontrolle ist.
Ja.
Richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Und Diagnose,
1 Woche, 3 Mal Diagnose, zum Beispiel,
und Neuse,
und Gewichtverlust,
zum Beispiel 1. Diagnose,
Hypertriose,
und dann auch unkontrollierte Diabetes mellitus,
Danachchioliac.
Ah, ja, okay, das macht nicht als Erstes auf der Hand.
Okay, ja.
Das Einzige, was eigentlich so ein richtig hammer Hinweis war,
war diese Geschichte mit dem Nudelessen.
Ich glaube, da hat es auch bei Dr. Thor-Dun
klingen gemacht,
als er gesagt hat, nach dem Nudelessen hat er ganz doll Bauchschmerzen gehabt.
Ja, aber das war Schlüssel.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und das war, glaube ich, auch so gemacht in dem Fall jetzt.
Tatsächlich finde ich auch,
dass die Geschichte mit dem Diabetes,
ich habe überlegt, ob ich das weglassen soll.
Aber ich wusste nicht, was ich dann mit dem Fall mache,
ob der dann überhaupt gar nicht mehr passt.
Ich bin halt selber kein Arzt, das ist mein Problem.
So, und die,
was ich überlegt habe,
macht man nicht heute tatsächlich
ganz schnell nach der Geburt
so ein schnell-zuliaci-Test,
gibt es da nicht irgendwas?
Ja, das ist ja immer,
das Zuliaci ganz früh
in der ganz frühen
U-Untersuchung irgendwie abgeklärt wird.
Bin mir aber nicht sicher.
Hat jemand ganz kleine Kinder, der das weiß?
Sechs Jahre,
fünf oder sechs Jahre, macht man das.
Ah, da macht man das, okay.
Ja, gut, da hätte es da auffallen lassen.
Ja, genau.
Gut, eine Sache,
vielleicht noch so zur Ergänzung.
Irgendwo habe ich etwas gelesen
von so einem H2-Atem-Test.
Weißt du, jemand, was drüber?
H2, also so ein Wasserstoff,
das praktisch durch die,
jetzt muss ich wieder überlegen, wie das war,
die alte Gasbildung
durch diese Darmenzündung
vermehrt
Wasserstoff in der Aus-Atem-Luft
drin ist und dass man das nachweisen kann.
Ja, das war für Haschblöri.
Kann das sein?
Ja, das war ein Test für Haschblöri.
Ah, okay.
Ja, dann habe ich das verwechselt.
Gut, und dieser
Antikörpertest,
das war tatsächlich so ein, da gibt es ein Gluten
und Gliadin,
gibt es auch einen solchen Antikörpertest?
Ja, Antikliadin, ja.
Ah, siehst du, da kommt
Deksylose-Test, okay?
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ja, gut.
Haben wir dem Fall ja doch noch ein bisschen etwas abgewinnen können.
Ja, Emre, bist du zufrieden
mit einer Fremd-Anamnese?
Ja, ja, das war
sehr angreifend.
Von Meisterfella.
Ja, also ich finde jetzt natürlich noch ein paar
ganz andere interessante Sachen darin.
Demnächst kriegst du noch mal einen Meinzerfall.
Okay, super.
Alles klar.
Gut, ja, dann sage ich für heute,
schön Dank fürs Mitmachen, schön Dank
für die gute Betreuung durch mein Doktor.
Und ja, wir sehen uns
wieder, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Nächste Mal.
Heute ist schon Dommasdag, ne? Ja.
Ja, sind irgendwelche Arbeitswürdigen am Wochenende?
Nein.
Nicht gut, keiner direkt vor der Prüfung.
Nein, okay, dann sehen wir uns Dienstag wieder.
Ja, okay.
Alles schön gesund bleiben, ja, gerne,
ciao, ciao, tschüss.